hi we're going to go over how to set up
allegro on a cmake
and build uh with ming gw
i'm going to use c-line just because it
uh works well with cmake but you can use
whatever you want
so let's get started
do a new project
i'm gonna call this a leg hello just for
the heck of it
it gives us a little whole project
thanks windows defender for not
understanding
my editor if you want to do this with
ming
gw we've got to install main gw
i'm sure you didn't see that one coming
did you gw.org
go to downloads
get the latest setup i'm using the
32-bit version
so do that install it and you're good to
go
once you have it installed you'll have
it on the root of your drive
right here it'll look like this
so drill down into it all right next
thing you want
is you want to go grab the allegro files
legrow.cc
files i'm using the 5.0
uh this version right here grab the zip
save it i've already downloaded it so
i'm getting another copy
a little redundant but no worries so
there it is
you just want to unzip it basically
because they're uh
zipped up oh god this green shirt it's
not going well with my
okay whatever it's fine the green screen
okay so you unzip it
you'll notice these same folders you
just drag them in
to here not into a folder but on the
outside
it'll merge them in i've already done
this so it's asking me to replace
but if you're doing this for the first
time it'll just happen
[Music]
but yeah you just want to move them in a
little pile in there
and you'll see if you go in there you'll
see allegro 5
and there's a bunch of others i'm using
c line this is where you can go get it
it's free for students otherwise it's
paid
30-day trial there are other editors you
can use that are about the same
you can use cmake on visual studio which
is free
and there's code blocks and other ones
too
or you can just figure it out in the
terminal if you want basically i'm using
cmake to set everything up here
in your project file you want to go to
file
settings
and under build execution deployment
tool chains you just want to make sure
it's on ming gw
the default project is going to give you
a main as a cmake i'm just going to show
you how to get
the hello world working just getting the
legroom window started
and i'll show you where to go from there
so this is the default thing
that it gives you for cmake the thing we
really need to do is
link gw and link
uh legroom when you do that with target
link libraries at the bottom here
link gw music 32 and then you also want
to link the allegro
thing which is depending on what version
it's going to be this
allegro 5.0 monolith md debug
in here if you look at live you'll be
able to find all these
[Music]
there dot a files
i'm not entirely sure which ones you're
supposed to use i'm using uh
which one i'm using monolith okay
maybe someone in the comments will know
or can explain this
basically you got to use one of these
dot a's i'm using this one
right here instead of uh
live at the front it's just dash l
so now we need some code so you got to
do your includes
you mainly need this to get a window
this is for the native dialogue which
i'm going to use for the error cases
so first of all you want to declare a
allegro display pointer to a lego
display
attempt to knit your display
with a l in it which returns a bull
i'm just making it so that if it uh
returns false it throws an error and
exits of course
with the return so if it gets past that
i'm gonna go ahead and
create a display
and we're going to make sure that's not
null and if it is we're going to show an
error and exit
and uh if we do this
we're good we want to destroy this
display at the end this is just going to
flash real quick
and do a compile here
but if you want to see it sit for a
while if you're building a game you're
probably going to want a game loop
after you set up your display
um so i'm going to use a quit uh boolean
to control my loop here
i'm just going to do sleep for five
which is part of a uni standard here
just so it shows the window for five
seconds and then it sits quick to true
and exits the loop
i essentially don't really need the loop
here
because i'm just sleeping for five so i
could literally just do this
and get the same effect but if you're
doing a game you want some kind of loop
of course
[Music]
okay well there you go there's a hello
world if you want to find out
more about allegro more tutorials more
how to get a game going in it
um well after you get this hello world
it's big step
there's lots of little projects here
resources
there's a lot of there's a lot of stuff
online about how to do this so
there you go hope you enjoyed this video
and i'll see you in the next one
you